coffee on a Tuesday is blog 17 year for
mankind is a lot like a day for a man he
wakes up does a bunch of stuff thinks a
bunch of stuff and then goes to sleep
now he sleeps not because his muscles
are too exhausted to go on not really
the body can take a lot he sleeps
because his mind is exhausted it needs
time to digest all the thousands of
pieces of information it consumed in the
day short-term memory is transferred to
long-term memory or tucked away in the
subconscious or forgotten entirely I
like to picture little men with manila
folders and glasses putting things away
in filing cabinets and sometimes the new
memories rub up against the old members
and where they touch sparks appear we
see those sparks as dreams well as for
mankind we you all and I are the little
men with manila folders and it's up to
us to decide what gets transferred to
long term memory and what gets tucked
away the subconscious it or what gets
forgotten entirely the only thing I
wonder though is if there was a way you
could see it what would the dream of a
year
good evening tonight I can report to the
American people and to the world the
United States has conducted an operation
that killed Osama bin Laden the leader
of al-qaeda it was nearly ten years ago
that a bright September day was darkened
worst attack on American people
our series into our national
I don't please
cloudless September sky
it's intense desire to do the will of
God because that is the way you have now
been designed by God because I want to
be entirely clear no one wants to
default Full Faith and Credit of the
United States government so I've said
this before but it's worth repeating
it's in Apple's DNA that technology
alone is not enough that its technology
married with liberal arts married with
the humanities that yields us the result
that makes our heart sing
his wife
I've made clear this does President Bush
did shortly after 9/11 our war is not
against Islam because bin Laden was not
a Muslim
and doubters - in other words that the
discussion about what is good what is
beautiful what is red
why is that important why would I like
to do that is that's the only
conversation worth having whether it
goes on or not after I die I don't know
but I do know that it's the conversation
I want to have while I'm still alive
you
hey you wake up time to get up